- Wow, I'm blown away. I'm gobsmacked.
First, I would like to
thank the organizers
for inviting me to speak
at this lovely event.
(audience laughs)
I had nothing to do with that.
This has been a wonderful meeting.
I'm gonna try and not mess
it up here at the end.
So everyone's been showing pictures
of the birthday boy.
Here's the oldest baby picture
I could find of circuit QED.
So as Leo mentioned,
and many of you know
we have a kind of tradition in the group,
which has kind of fallen by the wayside
with PowerPoint and everything,
but, like, people would bring a printout
and we'd date it and sign
it and things like that.
And so this is a printout
that I think Andreas put on my door.
It's a phase of a dispersive
measurement versus gate charge.
And he just put the two, you
know, double question marks,
like he wasn't even sure.
It's just really, but it's
periodic and gate charge.
So it may be like we're
finding the Cooper pair box
with this dispersive measurement.
And a lot of people have
also been asking me,
"Is your birthday today?"
My birthday is actually the 24th.
And you can notice here,
this apparently occurred on the 25th.
(audience laughs)
So this was Andreas bringing
me a 40th birthday present.
So for all the people I'm
currently working with,
what are you bringing me for my birthday?
(audience laughs and applauds)
Bring yourselves. That'll be enough.
And, you know, it was an amazing time.
Things went rather quickly.
We had the dispersive
measurement by the March meeting,
like, in beautiful form.
We came back and actually my
recollection is Andreas really
wanted to get the vacuum Rabi splitting
by tuning everything into resonance.
I said "That's too hard.
Let's just write this up."
I give you like two weeks
after the March meeting to
get the vacuum Rabi splitting.
And so here it is, I guess this was April,
maybe we had it working already.
This is already like the draft
of the figure for the paper
and we mailed it off.
I think the first person we showed this to
is I sent it off to Jeff Kimball,
who had been my instructor
for applications
of quantum physics back at Caltech.
And I'm not sure he ever forgave me
because he was the first
to observe this in the atomic
domain and it was really hard
and they never quite got
to as much cooperativity
and all that as these things.
It was my first "Nature" paper.
We didn't get on the cover of "Nature."
I don't know if they still do this.
They invite you to submit
some candidate cover art
and apparently the mistake
we made was letting Dave
draft the cover art.
(audience laughing)
And so you see, you can read it here,
maybe it's faint.
Biology NIH decides to
spend money on physics.
Chemistry gives up in the
face of bio and the physics.
And so if anyone who is making
the decision was not like
a quantum physicist, we were
clearly gonna get posed.
But I wanna say thank you.
Here's the picture of
sort of the circuit QED
core back in the day
and it was a wonderful time as
you know, a privilege to work
with such special people.
And you know, not only
'cause it was early in the lab
doing experiments and things
and we were still feeling our way along
but also 'cause we were
learning this language
of quantum optics and how
to apply it to circuits.
And I remember when we posted the paper,
many of the people in the field said,
"Think that was a great paper
but what's a Purcell effect
and why is there a vacuum Rabi?"
And like you know, took
a while for people.
Now everyone knows this lingo,
and I also want to say thank you to
my partners in crime
for the last 20 years,
Steve and Michel.
I mean what a privilege to work with two
of the best scientists on the planet
for all these 20 years
in close collaboration.
And I don't think that's something that
you're supposed to expect when you go
into this as a line of work.
And there's been incredible progress.
We've heard a lot about it in
this meeting in the 20 years.
You know, we've gone from
nanoseconds to milliseconds.
That's called something, I forget what.
Readout fidelities have gone up.
We've heard, you know, really
amazing numbers even advancing
in the presentations in
this meeting complexity.
I guess we have to add a zero Jerry,
a thousand qubits.
Size, we went from like a
two by seven millimeter chip
to 30 millimeters as Andreas told us.
UN told us that we've gone from zero mass
to I think it was 16 micrograms.
Maybe there's other numbers
that are bigger than that.
The funding, I don't know.
And I was only thinking
about the academic funding.
Let's not even think about
the private sector funding
that goes into it, but of
course there's the headcount
and so it's amazing to
see all these people,
everyone working in this space
and I just wanna say
thank you to the community
for all the work you've done.
It makes us look good. So
thank you very, very much.
Okay, so that's the summary
of the maudlin part.
What I thought I'd do,
instead of giving like a sort
of retrospective of everything,
which you heard a much better job
from Steve Griffin already.
I'd tell you about some of the
recent stuff that we're doing
because after 20 years I think
it's still not getting old circuit QED,
we're still finding out all
kinds of exciting new things
that you can do and you know,
one bit of progress leads
to another bit of progress
and you know in particular
we've been continuing
to bust our heads on this
very difficult problem
of quantum error correction.
And I think we might be
actually turning a corner
and being able to make some real progress.
But it's also kind of fun
because we've gone back
to basics a little bit
and we're reinventing even the
way we do our bosonic qubits
with this dual-rail encoding.
So I'm gonna tell you about some of that
and some of the results and
it's actually joint results
'cause we have a
collaboration between my lab
and the group of Shruti
and Steve on campus
as well as the company in science park,
and there's probably lots
of people in the audience
here from both organizations.
So we've already heard a
lot about error correction.
In principle, the idea is easy
just redundantly encode your
information one bit
or one quantum coherence in
three separate physical entities
and then if all you had was bit flips,
you would be able to be protected
to first order from those.
The problem is of course
now you have encoded
your information in three qubits,
which have all three of
them errors of their own.
And so when you think about trying
to actually gain from this,
the ideas you're gonna
be gaining exponentially
but you're losing as you put
in more of these elements.
So if you think about trying
to reach break even, you start
with just having some decay
of your information according
to whatever the lifetime of that is.
And then even if all of the qubits
are as good as your best one,
you're still gonna decay
three times faster.
But we're told okay, if we can
actually measure these errors
and either correct them or stabilize them,
remove the entropy in some way
or even just take account
of them in the bookkeeping
of the way we interpret the
results of the algorithm.
That'll be okay provided we can measure
sort of quickly enough that
multiple errors don't occur.
But of course we'll still be
losing no matter what we do.
But the goal of course of these
things is to really be able
to get some significant
quantum error correction gain
and it's harder than just losing a factor
of three in the beginning because
of course qubits don't just
have most of them a single kind
of error, they have
multiple kinds of errors
and so you need to have a
larger code than just three.
Maybe you need to do the
surface code which is two
dimensional sort of roughly speaking.
Shruti probably won't
like this one dimension
for doing bit flips, one
dimension for doing phase flips,
but we're told it's okay
because there's a finite threshold.
There's a point here where as
long as we can get the devices
to be better so that the
error rate is less than about
a percent or so, then we can start
to gain from this error correction
and indeed the logical error
probability will be suppressed
as we increase the distance
or the size of this code in a way which is
exponential in this ratio of
how well we do pass the threshold.
And it's great because
superconducting circuits
and qubits have advanced
to the point where yeah
indeed even the two qubit
errors can be better
than a percent but they're not
a lot better than a percent.
And so we're still kind of
right on the cusp of this
and so things are still
pretty challenging.
So nonetheless there's been all kinds of
amazing demonstrations.
I'm super impressed at the amount
of effort that's gone in
both on the industrial side
but even in some of the
academic labs on scaling these
things up and you know, people have sort
of successfully demonstrated
a lot of these concepts
and we're ready to go in some sense.
But here at Yale, our strategy
has been a little bit different.
Instead of trying to scale everything up
and then hopefully getting
a little bit further
past the threshold, we thought
we would do the following.
So you know the story I suppose
to choose a hardware efficient approach,
we're going to use a qubit
or something to store the
information that has fewer kinds
of errors and hopefully
slower errors to begin with.
And we're not gonna
basically use the hardware
to do the whole thing.
We're still gonna need to use
of course conventional
error correction codes.
But what we want to do
is make a distance three
or sort of deal with the first round
of error correction in some built-in way
using the physics of the devices.
And if we can really control
the propagation of the errors
and all of that, then when you
concatenate these things into
larger codes, you could really
be way past the threshold.
The basic idea is well
okay if we're at a sort
of a percent level now, if
we could somehow in hardware
get just a distance three,
we'd be able to kind
of have a squaring here of
this physical probability.
And when you stick that
into your higher order code,
now you'd really be past the sort
of thresholds for most of these things.
So the question is, is there a way to kind
of make yourself first order
robust to hopefully as many
of the errors as possible
so that you only fail
if you have two errors
and you can sort of take a
typical performance of 1%,
which is similar for
readout, for two qubit gates
and lots of other initialization
and go to sort of numbers
that would be orders of magnitude better.
And we also had this really
nice talk setting things up
from Shruti Puri, from whom
we've learned a lot about error
correction saying that not
all errors are created equal.
Note the punctuation in
the title slide, John,
you're gonna keep track,
you're gonna count for me.
But you know there's a sort
of a hierarchy of errors
and some errors are easier
to correct like the erasures.
You can also benefit if
your Pauli errors are biased
and you have a sort of
hierarchy of those things
and you really need to avoid leakage okay?
And so that's something we're going to try
and take to heart here
building into the hardware.
So the idea here is we want to maximize
the power of the cavities in
circuit QED which have a kind
of natural noise bias.
So we've been working a lot
with this flipped paradigm
if you like, of circuit QED.
It's not that the transmon
qubits are the fundamental
primary interest and the
resonators are there for buses
or to prevent spontaneous emission
or to do readout,
but actually we want to use
the cavities themselves also
as information carriers.
And the reason that we kind
of thought that was good is
I mean in fact we started
on the 3D cavities
to begin doing the
materials investigations
for IRPA in 2009.
And what we thought is by
making some 3D cavities,
we'll get cues of like 10 to the 11 or 12
and then that'll be the fiducial we use
to measure materials and everything.
We can make them be
queue of 10 to the eight
and get to several milliseconds.
But still, you know there's mysteries
even in just these 3D cavities
for why they're not better
than they are currently.
But nonetheless they can be
still better than transmon qubit
in terms of the lifetime
and importantly they also have
a large noise bias in the sense
that they have very little
intrinsic dephasing.
It's a linear element after all.
It doesn't have any Josephson junctions.
It has as smaller surface
participation ratio
as you can manage.
And you know, we can even
see that in experiments
where we have this full setup.
So this is from the
paper by Serge Rosenblum
and Phil Reinhold, where
they were able to sort
of tune the dispersive coupling
between the transmon and the cavity.
And there's a point here
where they turned off the interaction
so that you're no longer
suffering any dephasing
from the transmon,
you're still actually
suffering a T1 perhaps.
But anyway, this thing
had a cavity lifetime that
was not quite a millisecond
but then you see it goes really very close
to two T1 when you turn things off.
So from this and from
several other experiments,
we're able to place a bound
and only really a bound that
the intrinsic dephasing time
of these 3D cavities, for instance,
is at least 10 milliseconds or longer.
So there's a nice leverage there
and that's one of the reasons
why these bosonic codes,
which allow you to correct for
photon loss should be useful,
should be a way to get gain.
Okay, so again, not all
errors are created equal,
and in particular, these erasure
errors are a special kind.
What an erasure error means is that maybe
an error occurs in a qubit
but you have a unique signature,
there's something you can measure
that doesn't involve multi
qubit properties or stabilizers.
You have a flag that
goes off that allows you
to detect exactly when and
where a qubit went wrong.
And of course that means
that your information you have
is much larger, you can sort
of prevent the propagation of errors
and it means that the thresholds
for example can move much higher.
And so this work on
dual-rail and erasure qubits
in superconducting cavities
that we're doing is very much
inspired by the recent work
that Shruti did with Jeff
Thompson's group at Princeton
in which they looked at
being able to engineer
a neutral atom platform in which most
of the errors could be then detected
and by that process converted
from spontaneous emission
or other kinds of
mechanisms into something
that would be classified as an erasure.
And this idea of erasure
conversion I think is one
of the biggest sort of practical advances
in our understanding of how you should do
error correction in recent years.
There's another big advantage
of having something which
is erasure dominated
and that's because in a way
the errors are a little bit
more classical, they seem
like they scale better
or to put it more technically,
a surface code can
for example correct twice as many erasure.
Now you don't have to do
the surface code by the way,
there are of course if you
had predominantly erasures,
there are other codes that are small
and pretty efficient that you can use
to correct the erasures directly.
Okay, so that's led us to
kind of consider this new way
of doing bosonic error correction.
We're going to use a microwave cavity,
we're going to add some complexity.
We're now going to encode
the qubit in a pair
of microwave cavities or microwave modes
that have let's say different spatial
and different frequency,
different spatial modes
and different frequencies.
And the logical encoding
is that we're going
to have an excitation
which is either in Alice,
the left cavity or in
Bob, the right cavity.
And that just gives us a
simple two level system
which is your qubit space.
And the reason this is important
is now if the predominant
error that you're having is
of course the excitation, which
could be either on the left
or on the right disappears,
then you will go
to this unique state zero zero.
And in the story I'm gonna
show you there's multiple ways
that you can then detect the fact
that the photon has been lost
and you can even do that
without detecting whether it was
supposed to be on the left or on the right
using mid circuit erasures.
And so there's a syndrome
here, which means you can have
a way to detect these errors.
Now there's a proposal
paper that came out,
a paper about the way
in which to do the gates
and then this pre-print
on the archive showing
some of the results on the
basic properties of these qubits
that I'm gonna describe.
So the dual-rail is not new to us,
it's actually a very old idea.
Goes back to linear optics
of course and proposal
by Chuang and Yamamoto
in just a couple of years after Shore.
And there's many examples
of why you would wanna make
something differential.
You have two things and you look
for the difference between them.
And so there was proposal
for doing this dual-rail
with transmons from Amazon.
There's also a pre-print,
very contemporaneous from the Amazon group
demonstrating a dual-rail using transmons.
And then there are these earlier proposals
and work from Will Oliver's group as well.
So it's not that it's
necessarily a unique idea,
but I think the idea of doing
it using microwave cavities
and trying to leverage this
further noise structure you have
of low dephasing could prove
to be more advantageous.
So here's the thing, we want
to simplify our task of error correction.
Let's have something which
has a really nice structure
to its error processes
and what we you know can do
is use the physics we know
of circuit QED and these
cavities to kind of predict
what the major types of errors should be
and what their frequency of
occurrence might turn out to be.
So the erasures are gonna
be set by the T1 time,
that's the fastest error
process in the cavities.
So you want your dominant error process
to be the best kind to be an erasure.
And so that might be on
timescales of a millisecond.
If you're gonna do gates on sort of
frequency scales given by
the dispersive coupling
to a transmon for instance
or on microsecond timescales,
that means you might have a
sort of 10 to the minus three
probability of an erasure per timestamp
of the future computer.
Dephasing again we said
okay that's gonna be tens
of milliseconds so that'll
be at least an order
of magnitude suppressed.
Now what's a bit flip?
Well because we have these
two cavities at different
frequencies, essentially
any linear coupling just
renormalize the mode frequencies.
So if you're not doing
some non-linear process,
there's almost no way for
a five gigahertz photon
to move into a six gigahertz cavity.
The only thing that it could
do is relax to the ground state
and maybe get heated back up.
And so that process should be sort
of on timescales of minutes.
We'd give parts per million
or parts per billion
per kind of characteristic time
and like heating out of
even the two photon space
or whatever leakage, which
is the worst of all errors,
maybe just basically
effectively never happens
or you can, I think we can
have a non-destructive way
of measuring for leakage here
for almost all the processes.
So here's the full architecture.
You want to have these
two cavities, you need
to be able to do operations.
So you need a beam splitter
interaction between them
that's gonna be provided by some
Josephson parametric devices.
And then you're gonna have
ancilla transmon which is now
going to be used to
like load the photons in
to measure the resulting state
and to give you a interaction between two
of these dual-rail
qubits when you need it.
And the thing that we described
in this concept paper is
that using all the things we've
developed over the last few
years, we believe that
it's possible to detect all
of the dominant errors in
this system, the cavity loss
and when you're using the
transmon, the dephasing
and the relaxation of the transmon as well
and convert them into low
probabilities of erasures,
which makes them much easier to deal with
and that requires you to use this sort
of three level transmon trick.
Okay, so how do you do single qubit gates?
You want to transfer from left to right,
you need a beam splitter interaction.
We can do this parametrically using sort
of tools taken from the amplifier wing
of the circuit QED community
and applying them to the
high Q cavity domain.
And one of the things that's
nice is now essentially your
alarm mower frequency is the
difference in frequencies
between the two cavities
and you go back to sort
of the standard thing
of using amplitude and
phase of your single RF tone
that you adjust or two tones
if you're doing four wave mixing,
but it makes the kind of ideas of
how you control these things much simpler.
Now Shruti said, oh I told her,
or we tell her that
beam splitters are easy.
I felt like I had to defend my guys
and actually you know, we weren't thinking
of necessarily the dual-rail
and that we needed to have
super awesome beam splitters.
We did know that for all sorts
of bosonic error correction
things we would want to do,
we would need better beam splitters.
And so we launched a couple of years ago,
three or four separate projects
looking at different ways
of getting better interactions
and two of them worked pretty well,
actually almost equally well.
And so we're not sure yet,
you know, which is kind
of the preferred strategy.
The first of these was to use
this snail device pioneered in
Michelle's group here at Yale
and biasing it to the right flux point
where you have predominantly
three wave mixing
because we think not necessarily
that three wave mixing is
better than four wave mixing
our priority, but because
if you reduce the number
of unwanted processes that'll help you
get a cleaner interaction.
And so we figured out a way
to get sort of DC flux bias
and RF drive into one of these
two mode post cavity kinds
of devices with this thing that
looks like the right flyer.
And we could show sort of
parametric oscillations
here between the left and the
right between Alice and Bob
that look like this and
they look sort of like
a Rabi oscillation but not,
because they're sort of
falling down toward the ground.
And that's a good thing,
that's an important sign.
What that means here is that
we're doing fast operations
and that predominantly we
are preserving the nice air
structure of the cavities.
So we might be adding a
little bit of extra relaxation
but usually that's very small
but we're adding even less dephasing.
Dephasing would take
you sort of to something
where the photon is in
one or the two boxes,
but you just don't know where, which one.
But here what's happening is
really the predominant thing is
just that the photon's being lost
and that means we can
treat it as an erasure.
The second scheme is using
this parity protection
and sort of flux pumping a squid device,
which is essentially a transmon
but pumped in a different way.
Again, this is not earth
shattering groundbreaking news
for the amplifier community.
It's just us learning to do it in a way
that doesn't spoil the
hundreds of microseconds
to milliseconds lifetimes
of these devices.
And so again, you can get
very nice swap oscillations
between things with this device
we could go even a little
faster and get down to swap times
of like a hundred nanoseconds
or beam splitter rates
of a couple of megahertz.
And indeed this looks a
bit like a Rabi oscillation
so we can treat it as such
and say let's just see
what we can do if we change
the amplitude in the phase
of this beam splitter such that we do
randomized benchmarking on
this block sphere formed
by the single excitation
manifold of Alice and Bob.
And what we could see is something
where we could do actually
thousands of gates.
The raw gate infidelity here is something
a little bit better than three nines,
but again we're falling
towards the ground state here.
So we actually can do a post selection.
We can measure which ones
of these randomized benchmarking
trials didn't suffer
the photon loss and see what
the fidelity is in that case.
And in that case when we
just post select on the fact
that we have to have a
photon in either Alice
or Bob, we're throwing
out about one in 1300
of the operations, but
it's improving the fidelity
by a significant amount.
Actually the referee said
what's the big deal about a few
tenths of a 10th of a percent,
it's a factor of four improvements.
So I'm sure they weren't in this room.
It is a factor of four improvement
in the overall fidelity,
which again is sort of confirming
that we're preserving the noise structure
where photon loss is the dominant thing.
Okay, so why are we excited?
This is like two orders
of magnitude almost faster
than we've been able
to go in other bosonic
codes like the binomial code
and also about two orders
of magnitude higher fidelity
for doing single qubit operations.
Okay, so now what I wanna do is switch,
by the way I'm sort of indicating
which lab did the experiments
with the little logo in the
upper right hand corner.
So now I wanna switch
and tell you about using some very
precise measurements with
these dual-rails to try
and confirm more about
this error hierarchy
and be more specific about the phase flip
and bit flip rates and
all that sort of stuff.
So what we're going to do here is an end
of the line projective
measurement of the dual-rail qubit
and we're going to be able
to build into it this erasure detection.
So just as a reminder, right,
so you can do pretty good
readout of transmons these days.
You can read the ground state very well.
Typically the fidelity
is limited by the fact
that a readout takes
some hundred nanoseconds
to a microsecond
and the T1 time then gives
you about a percent or so
or maybe a few tenths
of a percent probability
that you've actually relaxed
during the course of the measurement.
The real problem here is
that a single error like a T1
during the measurement or a misassignment
of which blob you have in
your histogram leads to
an incorrect conclusion about the state
of the qubit going in.
Now in the dual-rail, there's
something really nice.
Basically all you ever have
to do in state preparation
and measurement is deal with fox states.
You need to make N
equals one in your cavity
and you need to measure N
equals zero or N equals one
and the dispersive interaction
with a transmon is just
built for that, right?
There may be a phase dephasing
back action when you do a
measurement of the photon
number with a transmon,
but it just doesn't matter if
you're doing a preparation in
one of the logical states or
if you're doing a measurement
in one of the logical states.
And so what you can do here
is you can have a transmon
for instance on both Alice and Bob
and you can make a measurement,
where you map whether there's zero
or one photons onto ground
or excited state of the
transmon ancilla that's attached
to those cavities.
And then you perform a
measurement of each transmon.
You can do that in parallel
and you get two bits of information
and those two bits of information
are gonna tell you whether
you're in 0 1, 1 0,
which logical state you're in,
but they can also give you
extra information, right?
They will oops, they will
also tell you for example
whether you get a zero zero
and then you can throw those out,
so you're getting extra information.
But also importantly,
you're getting something
which is now first order
insensitive to a single
error in this process
because you have to misassign
both of the cavities
to the wrong photon number in order
to actually get confused
about the logical state.
Now maybe if you miss
a photon n equals one,
call it n equals zero, you
think you're in zero zero
and there was still a photon around;
that's just some extra erasure
probability, as long as
that's small enough, that might be okay.
Here it's pretty big.
But we've been intentionally
trying to optimize
for the best discrimination
between the logical states
to use this as a sort of better microscope
to look at the coherence.
And so here are some
of the results that are
in this preprint.
There's sort of preparing
the zero and one.
And by the way the preparation
can be done redundantly
because you can prepare N equals one
and then use the transmon to check
and only go forward when both
cavities have been correctly
assigned to zero or one,
whatever you wanted them to be.
We have a model that takes
into account all the coherences
of the system and seems
to do a pretty good job
of predicting things.
And so when you try to
prepare, let's say one
or the other of the two logical states,
there's some probability
that you either actually
or in falsely get a think
that you've had an erasure.
But if you're in the code space,
it seems like you're getting
it correct at the couple
of parts in 10 to the four.
So you only misassigned your
logical state sort of 10
or 20 times out of a hundred thousand,
and that's quite a lot
better than the typical
readouts that one can do.
Okay so as I said, now this means
that we can separate out the
different error mechanisms
within this dual-rail and we can try
and look at whether it's
gonna actually fulfill
these predictions about the
hierarchy of the error rates
and the future performance you might get.
So here let's create a super position.
We do that by loading a
photon into one cavity,
doing a pi over 2 50-50 beam splitter
pulse parametrically,
and then delaying for some amount of time
for particular reasons we're
doing an echo in the middle
and then doing a pi over
two at the end after that.
And then at the end, you do
this projective measurement
in the logical basis and
throw away all the things
that are erased.
The purple here shows you the probability
that you've been erased.
That's just growing at a timescale
of a few hundred microseconds
which corresponds
to the T1 lifetime of the 3D
cavities that are used here.
And what you can see here is
Ramsey fringes or echo fringes
and they persist out,
you know, past sort of
the characteristic timescale
associated with the erasure,
because these are keeping only the shots
that are still in the logical code space.
And so this is Ramsey, this is echo
and the timescales here are pretty long.
What I also find amazing about
this is like if we just zoom
in here on the short time,
meaning the first 20 microseconds
of this dual-rail qubit,
there's no adjustment
here in the contrast.
This is taking the raw shots.
So what you can see here
is that you have resolution
that allows you to say okay,
we're only getting a few parts
in 10 to the three decrease
of our Ramsey contrast
or our echo contrast
after 10 microseconds.
So the probability of a
phase flip happening is
something like two times
10 to the minus four
in a microsecond, which is kind
of the timescale we're
gonna be interested in
for doing gates and the like.
And so that places again,
a bound on the dephasing
that says we're at least
bigger than a couple
of milliseconds in this case
I think we still haven't
seen the bottom here.
So there can be other exogenous effects
that look like dephasing,
and you know there's also
potentially issues with just
even though the measurement's very good
involving the measurement
precisely is a good question.
Okay, now I said that even
after you've gotten rid of
the erasures, there's supposed
to be a strong hierarchy between
bit flips and phase flips,
which again can be
advantageous at least if
you're just having the qubits
idling and sitting around.
So we can look at sort
of the bit flip rate
by either preparing one
of the two logical states
and then as a function of time looking
to see the probability
that you stay in the,
you think you stayed in
the initial logical state.
And this is actually polluted
here by the fact that
as the erasure become of order one then
or start rising here, it's just getting up
to, sorry, it's over here.
Yeah, erasures getting
up to about of order one.
Now any small probability
that you take the erased state
and assign it to be the wrong logical
state can kind of dominate.
But again, you see that
these curves are quite flat,
so we can place a bound here
that the bit flip lifetime
is something like, you know,
50 to a hundred milliseconds.
I mentioned that the bit
flip should be dominated by
relaxation and then heating.
In a separate experiment,
we can measure the heating rate.
The excited state thermal
equilibrium population
of these cavities is about
10 to the minus three
or 10 to the minus four.
So the actual bit flip
lifetime we would predict is
something like 15 minutes.
Okay, enough that it just
doesn't matter, right?
At least when you're idling.
Okay, so then let me,
I guess they didn't give
me a strict time limit.
So I'm gonna take a privilege
and go slowly and finish
off with a few things here.
So I mentioned that you want
to not only be able to do
a detection of the photon loss at the end,
but you also want to be able
to check for erasures during
an operation and you
want to do that in a way
that's not also gonna
perturb the logical state.
So if we wanted to measure
a change in photon number
or a photon loss in one of
the usual bosonic codes,
what we would do is
monitor the cavity parity.
Here to detect whether
there's a photon lost
from either Alice or Bob,
what we need to do is measure
the joint photon number parody
or we want to know whether
the system is in zero zero.
And so there's a way to do
that even if you only
have a transmon attached
to one of the two cavities.
And the reason for that is
when we drive a beam splitter,
what we're doing is swapping
the photon back and forth.
So if you like the transmon
is sensing both the photons
that started in Alice and the
photons that started in Bob
or it's effectively making these two
distinct modes look
indistinguishable okay?
And so I'll show you some
very recent results from de Graaf
and Sophia Xue who's in the audience.
Stein I think is out with something.
But what I'm gonna show you here is joint
photon number splitting.
So what they do is basically we just can
look at the spectrum of the
transmon here as a function
of frequency and the sort of probability
that you get excited.
And so just do spectroscopy
of the transmon, whoops,
while you change the beam splitter rate.
And to start with, if we
just are in the vacuum,
you know there's just one
peak, this is not surprising,
but if you start with one
photon in the system somewhere
and you begin driving the
beam splitter, what you see is
that here there are sort of
two peaks that are offset,
and as you drive the beam splitter harder
and harder, the states kind of evolve.
As I said, you're making things kind
of go from originally left and right
and you're turning these on,
you're getting these sort
of symmetric and
anti-symmetric combinations.
And so now the plus and the
minus state or what was left
and right are no longer distinguishable.
It's probably not the best,
this is the first time
I'm explaining this.
So it's probably not the best way.
But what you can also see here
in the spectrum is this faint
line that comes from the
residual zero zero population.
That's the peak at which the
transmon would be excited
if you had no photons in the system.
And so to do a check
for erasures on the fly,
what you do is just a spectroscopic pulse
about that frequency, which
takes a time of order kai
or kai over two actually,
because you're only sensing
the photons half the time.
And so we'll drive with
a beam splitter here,
which is on the order of
kai, the dispersive coupling
and look at what results.
And so here is sort of performing a pairs
of these erasure checks.
If we start with a superposition,
you can see the following kinds of things.
So there's some probability that per check
you have an erasure actually occurring,
that's the green line.
There's some increased probability
of falsely declaring an erasure.
So that's something like 4% per check.
But then if you look at the decay
of the Z logical information,
it's pretty slow.
In fact it actually seems
to improve the contrast of the Ramsey.
So we can infer from
that that there's sort
of a few tenths percent probability
of inducing a phase flip
per one of these erasure checks.
And you can also do the same thing
to look at the bit flip rate per check.
This doesn't come because of
heating or something like that,
but because you're swapping many times
and you need to make sure you've done
the swaps precisely enough.
So a little bit the phase
of the beam splitter or the precision
of the beam splitter turns into something
that looks like bit flips.
Okay so this kind of thing is
the primitive that you need
for doing two qubit gates.
And so again, in these concept papers
we describe a way of doing the gates.
What you need to do if you want
to do an entangling operation between two
of these dual-rails is engineer some kind
of an interaction between them.
And so if the two individual
dual-rails here share
a beam splitter and you
drive that beam splitter,
you can effectively measure
the joint parody of these two,
which will depend on not
whether you're erased
but on which logical states
the two qubits were in.
And you can make this kind
of exponentiation gadget,
where the transmon will
end up in the ground state
at the end provided you
did everything right
and you impart a ZZ phase
on this pair of qubits.
And of course the
transmon now is being used
to give you the non-linearity to sort
of engineer this curve.
The downside is you're suffering
from transmon decoherence,
but with the three level transmon
by detecting the transmon
at the end, both relaxation
and dephasing can be found
and turned into erasures.
And so we get a sort of a
flag just like you would want,
not only of when a qubit's been erased,
but when a gate goes wrong
and we can classify that
as well as an erasure,
although it'd be an erasure
now on a pair of qubits.
So if one just puts in kind
of typical coherence times
and typical dispersive couplings,
that means this gate will take
on the order of a microsecond
or two and the erasure errors
should be on the percent level.
That's kind of like the
standard problem everyone has.
But the residual Pauli errors come from
sort of second order things
or the intrinsic dephasing
rate of the cavity.
And we think those might
even be on the order
of 10 to the minus four.
And so now you don't want
to talk about the fidelity,
you have to talk about
multiple kinds of fidelities.
What's the probability of
this erasure error occurring,
which is easier to deal
with than the probability
of a Pauli error occurring.
And again, these erasure errors,
they can be corrected more rapidly
and they have a higher threshold.
And so together with Shruti's team,
we've done some simulations
for this system by the way.
That means that if you have,
maybe I should go back for one sec.
Having a factor of a hundred
between these is kind of nice
because it means that
essentially you are gaining even
with your sort of factor of five or 10
past the erasure threshold,
something like beating the
traditional surface code
threshold by a factor of a hundred.
So you'd sort of like to have these things
spaced out in this nice way.
So if we do some simulations with kind
of typical coherence properties
and you can get erasure rates
on the order of a percent,
or I mean maybe a little
bit less than a percent
and you really can get Pauli
errors on the order of 10
to the minus four, even though
you're post-selecting on all
the gates that went wrong, the
surface code can correct for
that and give you something
which in principle should have
an error correction gain of
something like one to two orders
of magnitude per layer.
So that feels like something
that's actually worth building
into a code and scaling up.
So the sort of lesson here,
if you didn't take away any
of the details is that there's a cheat,
error detection is kind of a way
to bootstrap yourself potentially towards
full error correction.
So that's I think quite amazing
and something I learned again
from from Shruti and Jeff.
So can you make this
thing into a surface code?
Yes you could.
It's not a small parts count,
so that might not be an RSL job,
but you only need actually
coordination three
between your individual
cavities to give you sort
of a 2D grid of these dual-rails.
And you also don't need
a transmon on every site,
as Shruti was saying, you
can sprinkle them around.
You might only even need
transmons on your measured qubits
in the surface code for instance.
And again, you can also
use other smaller codes.
3D cavities are not the only
thing inspired by the kind
of work you just heard about from Natalie
and working together with
Natalie and Andrew's team,
we have replicated this tantalum process
and in this preprint
from my student Suhas,
we demonstrated that we
could sort of have a budget
that predicts why a hybrid
transmon is about 300
microseconds, but also why
a on-chip resonator made
of tantalum should always
beat the Josephson junction.
Basically you can have a lower
surface participation ratio,
so you don't have to
think of linear resonators
as only the 3D things, no
matter what materials you have,
what form factor you make,
you should always be able
to make a longer T1
and a much longer TFI
for a linear resonator.
So that's maybe the reason why
you might wanna do these things.
And so the fact that
these are always longer
and that this now becomes
a little bit more modular
and easier to scale sort of looks
like a very nice thing as well.
Okay, so thanks for indulging me.
I'm not sure how long I went on, I wanted
to thank the entire
team, so both on campus
and at QCI and thank very
much Shruti and Steve
and maybe I will just
leave some conclusions
and summary here and take any questions.
Thanks.
(audience applauding)
There's a couple.
- So this of course it's a very nice talk
and this is very exciting,
this new type of error correction.
In the CAT code paper of Niem and Andre,
there was a optimization
that had to be done on
how frequently you do the
measurement and checking.
How does that work here?
- Yeah, so I don't know
that I understand all
of the details of that yet.
Let me go back to the mid circuit check.
So you know, if you're trying
to correct for these erasures
in a higher level code
and not just do post
selection, then you have to
interrogate and perform this check.
You'd like to do the check
as frequently as you can
and it matters what the
back action is, right?
And so these sort of bit flip
and phase flip probabilities
per check are the kinds of
things that will enter in
and there's gonna be some
optimal measurement strategy
depending on the T1 of
your cavity and so on.
But you know, in the sort of CAT code,
you're basically exciting the
transmon a hundred percent,
the whole time in this spectroscopic thing
you're just exciting it primarily
when you've already had an erasure
and so you then don't care
about the kind of back action
that limited the CAT code.
But in addition, sort of Kai T1 in
that experiment was
something like 20 I think.
And so here effectively
it's getting up towards
a larger number, like 500 maybe.
So stay tuned. That's
an interesting question.
I think that trade off
is universal no matter
what you're doing in error correction.
- So the very top of Shruti
pyramid was biased erasures,
and I guess you don't have
any biased erasure here
because your encoding is
zero one and one zero.
Is there anything, like are you just
so far out that it doesn't matter
or is there anything to
gain from trying to come up
with a new coding scheme where
you can have biased erasures?
- Right, so indeed biased
erasures can buy you another,
what is it factor of two
or so in the threshold.
I don't know of a way
to have biased erasures
for just the cavity photon loss.
I do think it may be possible
to get biased erasures
for the gate errors.
Basically, you can figure
out where the qubits were
based on what you see
after the transmon has caused a problem.
- [Participant] Well I guess
if you had a logical space
that was, I don't know,
two zero and one one
or something silly, wouldn't
that be a biased erasure?
Because then you would decay
out of the two. Stay it faster.
- Yes but what you want
is something where,
yeah, okay, but maybe you're just making,
you want biased erasures,
but you don't wanna get biased erasures
by making one of the rates faster.
You wanna make one of, you
know, the one of the rates go
to zero right?
- Something to be slower.
- So that's another aspect in
which I think the dual-rail's
kind of one of these happy surprises.
You know, you only need one photon.
So the overhead in terms of the
how many times kappa is
pretty minimal, so...
- So this is really cool, cool work.
Post selection is also the domain
of weird physics, like
anomalous weak values
and non Hamiltonians.
Do you get weird effects
from those things and or
can you use like weak value
amplification to make errors?
- I haven't thought about
the weak value amplification.
There is one bug that a dual-rail has
that's sort of non-Hermitian.
So if your cavity lifetimes
are not equivalent,
then if you wait around
long enough you will
almost certainly be in whichever
of the two cavities had the
slightly longer lifetime.
It turns out that kind
of evolution though is
sort of deterministic.
So if you just make sure that
you have an echo pulse midway
between when you're using
things, then you spend just
as much time in each of the logical states
with the excitation in each
of the physical cavities.
And in fact we see that that can sort
of undo this no jump
back action that you get.
And you know, there's
other reasons why it's nice
to have echoes in everybody's thing.
So I think that's not much of a penalty.
But if you have other ideas about what
to do, we should talk.
- Okay if we don't have any more question,
lets thanks Rob again.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, I think it's
gonna be then up to me
to close the conference.
So before you guys get up, I'd love
to thank all of the speakers.
This has been an amazing meeting.
Thank you all for coming.
(audience applauding)
(gentle music)